well grab the pups and get ready for the
epocharian
event happening the first weekend in
september and here to tell us all about
the event from the pup cafe and dog and
whistle is eric adams and my new friend
this is rocket hello everybody how are
you doing well thank you rocket came
dressed for the occasion i don't know if
you guys can see but he has a tuxedo on
so he's ready for a party or paw tea i
guess
tell us a little bit about this event
it's the first one but you're hoping to
make it an annual event right yes so
very excited to announce the epoch
herrion event uh so what we're what we
want to do is just bring a lot of things
to light so in terms of upcycling and
and what we do at the pub cafe is we
rescue different foods from different
distributors and restaurant partners and
converted to a sustainable product for
dogs so we're going to talk about
upcycling but then also bring awareness
to our non-profit partners so noaa's
animal house and then also the nevada
spca
we're going to be doing some donations
on the proceeds for that as well so we
got some live music
provided by the fergusons and then some
really cool food
amenities from vegas test kitchen and
peyote wow well it sounds like a party
and a lot going on and rocket here has
been sniffing away you said this is
rocket's favorite meal in front of us
tell us about some of the stuff you
brought with you today yeah absolutely
so these are all going to be located at
the cafe so we have rockets meal which
is actually his specialty meal so it's
roasted pork we got some spinach we got
some squash it is grain free a little
bit of canola oil and then some canine
complete supplement
we have our sweet potato treats which is
also available on www.dog and
whistle.com as well as in store at the
pub cafe
have you ever seen a dog cafe on
doordash i definitely have not
the pup cafe is actually located on
doordash so you're able to get your
meals delivered to your house from the
pub cafe so if you want to have any
nutritious meals delivered to your doggy
you can through doordash wow and really
excited to announce our newest item in
which we have it on pre-order is our
paul dobo so this is
upcycled single-ingredient meal toppers
that is currently available for
pre-order on
www.doggonewhistle.com well this is all
amazing eric and now my huskies at home
will eat well because you guys are on
doordash so really quickly where can
people come check out this event that's
happening yes we're going to be located
at the ferguson's downtown so 10 28 east
fremont uh on sunday september 4th
perfect all your information is on the
screen there thank you so much for being
here and thank you rocket all right